This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, Portlandia fans. Carrie Brownstein and Fred Armisen here. The Dream of the 90s is alive in podcast form. We're launching Podlandia, AEO, rewatch, our brand new podcast where we revisit every episode of Portlandia together, breaking down sketches, going deep on our iconic characters,
and pulling back the curtain on how it all got made. And we'll also be joined by the people who helped bring it all to life. Guest stars, collaborators, and friends, including director Jonathan Chrysler, the mayor, himself, Kyle McLaughlin, legendary musician Amy Mann, and many more. Kyle is going for it here. You fully improvised, not just words, but a song. Well, I thought you were all going to write a song.
I remember you thinking that. Listen to Podlandia. A.O. Rewatch on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. What's up, fam? I'm sports journalist Ari Chambers. Hey, what's up, y'all? It's your girl, Sam J. And we're the host of Everyone Watches Women's Sports, a new podcast from Together and I Heart women's sports. We're breaking down the biggest headlines. Naomi Osaka, showing out. Shout-hows to you, Naomi. The viral moments. I've been obsessed with Kashan Rock's
boxing journey. She looks good. Her combos are swift. And the stories everyone's talking about across women's sports. Because everyone watches women's sports. Listen to everyone watches women's sports on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. I'm Nick Terturo. You probably know me from NYPD Blue, the longest yard, or Spike Least Black Klansman. And on my new podcast, delivering happiness with Nick I deliver pizza to a new guest. I've shared a slice with everyone from Seth Rollins. What are you doing, my belt?
To Bill Burr. I don't think I've ever met somebody so exactly out of their mind as I am. And now, we even have more great guests coming up, including the great John Tuturo. It's called Happiness. Delivering Happiness. And many, many more. Open your free High Heart Radio app. Search Delivering Happiness with Nick Totoro.
And listen now. This is Chelsea Handler from Dear Chelsea. Every week, the news gets worse. the world gets crazier, and Yamanika is here to tell whoever's responsible, you're the problem. Do you know I just found out who Sidney Sweeney was? If he got a bunch of women,
then I should have a bunch of men. Do better or do less, so I don't have to do so much. I'm Yamanika, and I'm out. Listen to You're the Problem with Yamanika on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. I'm Nancy Glass, host of the Burden of Guilt Season 3 podcast. This is a story about a horrendous situation that destroyed two families.
It's a scorched earth war that shows just how far someone will go to get what they want. Cindy said I had to choose between the truth and my family, and I had to choose the truth. Listen to season three of Burden of Guilt on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello, everybody. I'm Gemma Spike, and welcome back to the psychology of your Twitter. 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show.
Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s psychology of your 20s psychology of my 20s. Today we are talking about the psychology. of insecurity. Yeah, I'm just going to bite the bullet and say, um, truth is I'm a very insecure person. I'm insecure about so many things from silly little things from my childhood, like, I don't know, my teeth straight enough that I was like teased about when I was a kid to big things. Like, am I a good friend? Am I doing well enough in my career? Being insecure, as you guys know, is a very lonely existence because the only way to truly process it is to often talk about it.
But A, we're too insecure to do that. That's our problem in the first place. And B, you really want the other person to say the right thing. Because one wrong phrase, one miscommunication, one wrong wording quickly can very much feed the insecurity and make it worse. So it remains a very silent thing and therefore has a very strong influence over us. I know for a long time, my insecurities just dictated how I saw myself more than any other factor, no matter what external evidence I had, no matter what happened beyond me, what validation I received,
whatever it was, my brain always came back to what am I insecure about. I'm sure it's very similar for many of you, but I think it was only when I started almost looking into the ancestry and the origin point of my insecurities, and I realized, you know, 90% of our thoughts are recycled. I was not inherently born insecure, and neither were you. I have been taught this self-consciousness, therefore it can be untought that I kind of started seeing my insecurities differently. And it's very core, how I see it now is that, insecurity is a protective mechanism that has outlived its psychological usefulness. This is how we're going to treat it today. And we're going to talk about where insecurity comes from, why a little bit of insecurity was perhaps useful for you, how it then goes on to transform into something that is definitely not useful over time, how to identify, you know, whose voice, whose influence shaped your insecurities the most, because that is an
important part of this equation and most importantly, how to start unlearning those recycled thoughts, how to start unlearning the negative ways you feel about yourself. Because as I said before, if insecurity has been borrowed, it can be returned. There is so much psychology to unpack. I'm literally not going to waste any more time with an intro for this episode. Let's just get straight into it. Stay with us. Let me start by saying this. Show me someone who claims to have no insecurity, and I will show you a liar. At the very least, I'm going to show you someone who uses mechanisms of denial, displacement, projection to cocoon themselves,
because the existence of insecurity proves the existence of ego, which proves the existence of your soul and your own consciousness. To not have insecurity would be to not be conscious. Here is the thing we need to make very clear, from the beginning of this episode, on some level, we are all insecure, and that insecurity does at times serve a very valuable psychological purpose. That self-consciousness we often hate is what allows us to approach life in a way that balances caution and courage. And it's what prevents us from slipping into what we call in psychology, but more specifically in psychiatry, delusions of grandeur.
We definitely don't want to go there. There is a Goldilocks level of insecurity that's like just right. That's kind of what I'm getting at. You know, if we're too insecure, our life becomes dictated by, our life becomes dictated by the potential judgments of others. Equally, if we are overly confident, our life becomes dictated in another way, by an inability to take criticism,
by an inability to hone our skills because we don't think there's anything we're bad at, by an inability to experience humility and most certainly to properly interpret opportunities that we are given every single day to be better. For example, there is research that was published in 2019 in the Journal of Personality and Social Psychology that found when people experience a mild level of what they call self-image threat, they are more likely to save, they're more likely to be financially prudent, and they make smarter financial decisions. So that's just one area you might be doing better at if you're an insecure person like me. Further theories have also suspected that a healthy amount of insecurity keeps people, as I said, motivated to improve
in relationships at work when it comes to their physical health, although that's definitely a gray area, a shaky area. It's also correlated with a greater openness to learning. You know, if you're overly secure, again, you just simply don't think you need to improve. Therefore, you will not. This is a deep belief I have. I say this to my friends all the time. I truly believe every single person needs to know one thing about themselves that could be better or that is a flaw in order to be a well-rounded human. Like, you have to have something that you know you are not good at if you want to claim that you are self-aware. There's also some evidence that it can drive greater social harmony as well. This is the evolutionary explanation for insecurity. Why we have insecurity,
you know, the evolutionary explanation claims that if something exists, it has to be useful. Their opinion is that insecurity and being a socially harmonious person requires acknowledgement that other people have complex inner worlds that we form a part of and that as we are a part of these complex in a world, people can have poor judgments about us. Those judgments matter. Therefore, the insecurity we have around them is important because it leads us back to the group. It nudges us into being a good person. If there was somebody who existed who never felt any level of insecurity about their behavior or their actions, they would become a very dangerous force. They would have no reason to control their urges or their behavior. So these theorists, these researchers,
just believe that insecurity in this sense doesn't have a positive force, doesn't have a negative force, it has a neutral force in that it maintains a level of social order. Of course, when this self-questioning bleeds into crippling levels of doubt or self-scrutiny, we have a problem. That's an interesting question in itself. When does it get to that level? More importantly, what makes somebody more or less insecure if we are all, according to this evolutionary theory, with like a baseline level of insecurity. Are we just born this way? Or are we shaped to be this way? What component is nature? What component is, I guess, nurture in a sense. Like where does that, where does that equation land? So let's start with nature. Firstly, our inborn temperament
naturally plays a big part. Just as all of us have different colored hair, eyes, so on. We all have different inbuilt temperaments. Temperaments are basically our natural state of being. Now, the four temperaments according to something called proto-psychological theory, are melancholic, choleric, phlegic, and sanguine. This is not our personality. This is a layer below our personality. Whichever one you are is said to correlate to how you naturally show up in situations, including how insecure or secure you are, how reactive or calm we are, how observant or judgmental we are. It's the building block for personality that comes before. If you have a melancholic temperament, you are more prone to deep-seated insecurity.
That is what the theory says. That is the basis of this self-consciousness you have. Researchers have gone a step further. They've long tried to measure just how much of our temperament and also our personality, including our level of insecurity, is actually hardwired within the genome. Basically, can we tell how insecure somebody's going to be based on their genes? One way that they've done this is through a large genetic study in the UK from 2016. They had over 100,000 samples in this study. And they explored whether traits like anxiety and emotional instability packaged together, this is what psychologists called neuroticism, whether neuroticism can be traced back to our DNA.
Researchers had participants complete personality questionnaires, measuring neuroticism and other factors, including insecurities, whilst they kind of analyzed their DNA. Literally, there was millions of genetic variations. They wanted to look at them all, correlate them to these self-reports, see if there was any patterns. What the researchers found is that their, isn't. There is not a simple insecurity gene. However, there are multiple genetic regions that play
a small role in dictating whether you are going to be a more or less insecure person. These common genetic variants that they found accounted for around 15% of the differences in neuroticism between individuals on their own holding for other things. So in other words, because I always find this confusing, in other words, about 15% of the variation. between those of us who are insecure or not, neurotic or not, can be linked to a specific genetic difference that is perhaps influenced you in that direction. And this genetic difference was one that the researchers were able to measure. Importantly, because when we talk about genes, I feel like sometimes this can get confusing. Genes don't determine your destiny. They're just a
blueprint. People can always build the house differently. Our environment, the way we are nurtured, these also shape whether some genes are more or less likely to emerge. Our choices also shape this later on. So your temperament, your genes, they're just the beginning. With that in mind, though, let's talk about some of those other ones. What are those, let's talk about the nurture component of this, how much of our insecurity is learnt. Short answer, a whole lot of it.
I think a lot of us can remember a time where there was like one critical moment that turned us from somebody who didn't think that much about our appearance or our personality or how loud we were or whether people liked us into somebody who thought about that a whole lot. What kind of events, one-off or repeated, trigger this? A bunch of them I want to talk to are lack of unconditional or lack of conditional love and approval from parents, sibling comparison, judgment from adults, bullying, body image, social media. to name a few that influence how insecurity shows up in us as individuals. And let's just start at the top.
Let's just start with conditional love. Put simply, and also put rather sadly, but not everyone had the fairy tale childhood that we collectively deserve. One of the most common roots of insecurity is experiencing love, attention, or approval as something that has to be earned, rather than as something that is freely given as it should be. In other words, you learnt that being accepted and supported is a luxury that does not have to be given to you all the time. This is what psychologists sometimes refer to as conditional regard or conditional positive regard.
It was a concept first explored by the very famous humanistic psychologist, Carl Rogers, who we literally talk about in every second episode. but Rogers believed children thrive when they receive unconditional positive regard. Love and acceptance is not dependent on achievement. It's not dependent on obedience or meeting certain expectations. When affection is only given in response to good grades, good behavior, sporting success, being the easy child or being a child that looks a certain way, that is when we begin to internalize this belief that my worth is.
conditional. If I'm not receiving love, there is something I'm doing wrong. Therefore, there is something I should be insecure about. Rather than thinking, I'm loved because I exist, we learn I'm loved because of what I do for others and I'm loved because of how I perform. Research by the psychologist Edward Desi and Richard Ryan has shown that environments where approval is contingent on a certain level of performance or appearance undermines our level of intrinsic worth and autonomy. And over time, this creates what psychologists call contingent self-esteem. I know a lot of psychology terms in this part, but contingent self-esteem, self-worth that rises and falls depending on external validation, therefore meaning that you are more likely to be insecure because external validation
is fickle. The sad thing about these circumstances, and I think about this all the time, they also create these limiting beliefs that restrict whether somebody can challenge that initial belief or not. It restricts what they feel capable of for the rest of their life. It is so tragic, but I often get these comments of people being like, you know, that sounds nice, but that's not for somebody like me. Or I did this episode recently that was like, I want to do everything, so I do nothing. And I was like, leave a comment down below of like, what is your big dream? What is the one thing you really want to do? And this person was like, I really wanted, I'm not going to say the job, because it will give it away, but it was like, I really want to do this, but like people like me
don't do that, and there's no way that I'll find success. And I was like, that is so sad to me. That is so tragic because, you know, you do have what it takes to succeed. But these early beliefs and these early words and these early feelings have put this restriction on you. And now you're out of the game. Like, you have taken yourself out of the game or more specifically, somebody's voice in your head is taking you out of the game before you can even try, and now it is guaranteed that you will not be successful. And it's interesting how that limiting belief becomes reality, just because you have been forced to think it time and time again about yourself. It becomes reality and we see it as, as soon as it becomes reality, we're like, well, that was always
destined to happen because of what these people told me, because they told me I wasn't good enough. Another way our upbringing influences, our insecurity levels, in a very similar way, but also a very different way is sibling rivalry and comparison, which we just did an episode on a few weeks ago. I feel like I do this all the time. I look into something and then it will like just keep popping up time and time again in future episodes. So apologies if you were up to date and if you already know what I'm going to talk about because you listened to that episode. But sibling comparison is a factor that like I do not see people talking about, hence why it deserves its part in this episode. It seems natural, it seems fairly common, it can be deeply damaging.
To some extent, comparison between siblings occurs because we are different and people who are different compared. But consistently feeling that you are less worthy than a sibling who excels at things, who is celebrated by your parents, who is smarter than you, who is more fun, he was more loved, who is easier, can create an ingrained sense of inadequacy from childhood that bleeds into your life beyond childhood and beyond your family unit. This is particularly the case with parental favoritism. I just read a New York Times article about this. Parents favoring one child over the other. This New York Times article essentially said, you know, there's been this back and forth around,
do parents have favorites? Do they not? And they looked at this 2001 study that wanted to investigate it once and for all. And it essentially found they absolutely do. The study was conducted at Purdue University. the research has recruited. 500 parents. Every one of these parents had to have two children or more. And they can't just outright say, like, do you have a favorite child? They ask them more sneaky questions. They ask them, you know, which child do you spend more money on? Who do you feel emotionally closer to? Like, who do you think looks more like you? Who are you more disappointed in? And they ask these questions plus a bunch more over like many, many years. They literally have been tracking some of these families for 25 years to the point where they're now looking at favoritism
that passes on to the grandchildren. Do you want to guess how many of these parents had a favorite? Two thirds. Two thirds of these parents had a preferred child, although very few of them admitted it. And that favoritism lasted over decades. Knowing you aren't your parents' favorite is shown to greatly contribute
to a higher baseline level of insecurity. Almost because, like, the call is coming from inside the house. Like, you get your initial sense of self-worth from your parents, if you can tell they don't like you, how are you going to overcome that? You know, if you've been compared and felt less than since you were a kid, explicitly, implicitly, obviously, not obviously, that is going to really deeply influence how you see yourself. The very famous American author, John Bradshaw, has also spoken about how when that turns into judgment and now having harsh or judgmental parents who really overcorrect you and really
want to make you feel bad as a way of discipline leads to an impoverished self-image and what he calls a shame-based identity. A shame-based identity is one that is rooted in failure versus success. Essentially, because of our childhood, as adults, if we grew up with harsh parents, our primary reaction to any setback, shortcoming, small mistake is to feel shit about ourselves, is to shrink and self-blame rather than look for opportunities or solutions to expand because we're waiting for somebody to come down and be like, bad, naughty. And you therefore, well, it's not you, your experience has put a stealing over your ability to grow. Now, unless we have a strong counterforce to this, such as, you know, a strong support system outside the family or really
great friends, or we tackle those early beliefs through therapy or similar, we just are left feeling that we are inherently unworthy. We inherently should feel insecure because the people who were meant to provide unconditional love and support couldn't. And what kind of parent can't love their child? Must be something wrong with us. When we're a kid, that's the other thing. We can't understand that this has nothing to do with us and everything to do with them because we don't have that self-awareness.
So again, it influences us deeply to our core. Let's talk about some contributors beyond the family system, shall we? We're going to do that. After this short break, stay with you. us. You've heard the chaos. Now you can see it. Do we want to jump right in? Watch all your favorite podcasts from start to finish right inside the free IHard radio app. Make some noise. Wooee! Catch every laugh and eye roll on shows like Bestie Listen. Hey Jonas and Las Culturistas. Now with full video. I'll just leave that there. It's the same hosts and the same chemistry
with all the hilarious moments you've been missing right on your screen. Open the free IHard radio app. Search video podcasts and tap watch. What's up, fam? I'm sports journalist Ari Chambers. Hey, what's up, y'all? It's your girl, Sam J. And we're the host of everyone watches women's sports, a new podcast from Together and I Heart Women's Sports.
Because let's be real. Women's sports is giving us way too much to talk about these days. So Kelsey Finler, she became the first female solo roer to go from California to Hawaii. My first thought is, like, what's up with the snacks? Like, what are we eating? The highlights, the rivalries, the breakout start. the moments to take over your entire timeline.
And the conversations that start during the game and somehow keep going all week. Every week, we're breaking down the biggest stories across women's sports. Naomi Osaka showing out. She beat Sabalinka. Shout out to you, Naomi. You get the palm, Naomi.
You get the palm for that. Because we're not just interested in what happened. We're interested in why everyone's talking about it. Because everyone watches women's sports. Listen to everyone watches women's sports. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. Hey, Portlandia fans.
Carrie Brownstein and Fred Armisen here. You know us, or rather you know them. Tony and Candice, Nina and Lance, Spike, and yes, the chicken. We've played a lot of iconic characters over the years, but today we're showing up as ourselves to tell you about Podlandia, AEO rewatch, our brand new podcast. Each week we'll revisit an episode of Portlandia from the very beginning, breaking down the sketches, exploring the backstories of our most iconic characters,
revisiting the Portland locations you know and love, and opening up about our creative process. How did any of this get made? Why do we think that was a good idea? We're ready to talk about it. And we'll also be joined by the people who helped bring it all to life. Guest stars, collaborators, and friends, including director Jonathan Chryssel,
the mayor himself, Kyle McLaughlin, legendary musician Amy Mann, and many more. Kyle is going for it here. You fully improvised, not just words, but a song, a melody. Well, I thought he was going to write. I thought you were all going to write a song. I remember you thinking that. Listen to Podlandia.
Ayo rewatch on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is Chelsea Handler from Dear Chelsea. Every week, the news gets worse. The world gets crazier. And Yamanika is here to tell whoever's responsible, you're the problem. If you come over here to play games, I'm a check you. Okay? If you do some in the news that don't sound good, I'm going to play you.
Join Yomeneika Saunders as she breaks down the weeks. most problematic stories on our new podcast. You're The Problem with Yamanika. Do you know I just found out who Sidney Sweeney was? New episodes weekly every Wednesday is part of my new network, the Dear Chelsea Network. If he got a bunch of women, then I should have a bunch of men. Do better or do less, so I don't have to do so much. So join Yamanika each episode as she answers one question.
Who's the problem? I'm Yamanika, and I'm out. Listen to you're the problem. with Yamanika on the I Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. I'm Nick Totoro. You probably know me from NYPD Blue, The Longest Yard, or Spike Lease Black Klansman. But I'm also from Queens, which means I know pizza. And on my new podcast, delivering happiness with Nick Totoro, I deliver pizza from
Prince Street pizza to a new guest. Are you delivering pizza now? Then we sit down for a real conversation. I've shared a slice with everyone from Seth Rollins. What are you doing my belt? To Alex Rodriguez. Just to let you people know, we're talking to one of the goats here. To Bill Burr.
I don't think I've ever met somebody so exactly out of their mind as I am. And now, we even have more great guests coming up, including the great John Tuturo. It's called Happiness. Delivering Happiness. Mariano Rivera. Oh, my God. And many, many more. Open your free high-heart radio app.
Search Delivering Happiness with Nick Totoro. And listen now. I will talk about this every day until the cows come home. home until people listen. If you were bullied as a child, even if you are over it, even if you don't see those people anymore, even if you don't think it was that serious, even if it was years ago, I am telling you right now, your baseline confidence level is already lower than the average person. The thing about bullying is that it often occurs when our self-concept is at its least stable and most vulnerable. If you think about our self-concept as a chart that kind of tracks alongside age,
between the ages of 12 and 17, you're going to see a massive dip in our self-concept. There was a survey, I think it was reported in the Journal of Psychology and Aging in 2002. It questioned over 300,000 people, aged 9 to 90, and the result showed that 9 to 12 years old is when we had our highest level of self-esteem, and then our self-esteem after 12 just plummets for an extended period of like five to 10 years. It's a very significant drop at the beginning of puberty. Both genders experienced equal drops in self-esteem. It was also when individuals were most likely to report memories of being bullied, and memories of bullying being at its highest intensity. So, that is when we're going to get hit right at that point where we are at our lowest. And it's a very
slow recovery from there as we get older. Just in general, our self-esteem levels out. Well, it only fully recovers from that drop in like our mid-50s to 60s. Like it takes 40 to 50 years to get back to how we felt as children again in adulthood. But it is very clear in the study and from many other studies that there are certain points that we are most sensitive to even minor knocks to our internal sense of self. And it also is these points where any damage is magnified. Bullying is always going to be a terrible experience. It's psychologically very violent, very disarming, but especially as a child or teenager, it's harder to escape, first of all. It's also harder to rationalize. It's harder to counterfactualize as well, because we don't
随着年龄增长，情况会慢慢恢复。总的来说，我们的自尊水平会趋于平稳。嗯，直到我们50多岁到60多岁左右，它才会完全从那种下跌中恢复过来。就像我们需要40到50年的时间，才能在成年期重新找回儿时的感觉。但研究以及许多其他研究非常清楚地表明，在某些时间点，我们对内心自我意识的微小打击也最为敏感。而且也正是在这些时间点，任何伤害都会被放大。霸凌永远是一种可怕的经历。它在心理上非常粗暴、极具剥夺感，但尤其是作为儿童或青少年，首先，它更难以逃避。其次，它也更难以合理化。进行反事实思考也很难，因为我们还
know who we are yet. We don't have that confident bodyguard to like step in and be like, I don't think that's true. It can take years to not have your bully's voice be the first thing that pops into your mind whenever something goes wrong in your life or whenever something goes right. And that leaves a lingering impact, obviously, on insecurity. Then sometimes, to make it worse, the bully isn't even one person or two people or a group. It is a societal system. It is a societal system that endeavors to bully all of us to make us feel bad for profit. I'm talking about social Here is a not-so-fun fact. The earlier you are exposed to social media, the greater your chances of what we call
不知道自己是谁。我们没有那种自信的保镖走出来说，我觉得那不是真的。有时候需要好几年时间，当你生活中出错或者顺心时，你的脑海中第一个浮现的才不是那个霸凌者的声音。显然，这会对不安全感产生挥之不去的影响。然后有时，更糟糕的是，霸凌者甚至不是一个人、两个人或一个群体。而是一个社会系统。这是一个努力霸凌我们所有人、让我们为谋利而感到内疚的社会系统。我说的就是社交。这里有一个不太有趣的现实。你接触社交媒体的时间越早，你患上我们所谓的
pathological and maladaptive insecurity. That's a scary term. But it's true. Frequent social media usage increases a psychological phenomenon known as self-objectification, whereby we view ourselves as a physical object first, something to be looked at, something to be hopefully liked and an emotional and psychologically complex individual second. When our thoughts about our physical form become negative or become inaccurate or the body standard changes as it does so rapidly these days, if we have higher levels of self-objectification,
病理性和适应不良性不安全感的几率就越大。这是一个吓人的词。但这是真的。频繁使用社交媒体会加剧一种被称为自我客体化的心理现象，即我们首先将自己视为一个物理对象、一个供人审视的对象、一个希望被喜欢的东西，其次才是一个具有情感和心理复杂性的个体。当我们对自身形态的想法变得消极或不准确，或者身体标准像如今这样瞬息万变时，如果我们有更高的自我客体化水平，
we risk being completely mentally and emotionally derailed because our sense, of self-esteem is once again conditional on something that isn't solid or stable and more specifically isn't internal. I think we associate body image issues with people who are in puberty, people who are like in their late teens, but with social media becoming more ubiquitous nowadays, body image insecurities are showing up younger and younger. There was one review, I think, in 2016, that identified body dissatisfaction in children under the age of six is increasing at a rapid rate because of social media exposure. There are heaps of estimates out there depending on what source you look at, but one study that
我们就有可能在精神和情感上彻底崩溃，因为我们的自尊感再次取决于某些不坚固、不稳定，更具体地说不是内在的东西。我认为我们往往将体形问题与处于青春期的人、十几岁后期的人联系在一起，但随着社交媒体在当今变得无处不在，体形不安全感正变得越来越年轻化。我想2016年的一项研究发现，由于接触社交媒体，六岁以下儿童对身体不满的现象正在迅速增加。根据你看的来源不同，有无数的估计，但有一项研究
measured body image in a group of 11 to 16 year olds in the UK found that 79% thought that how they looked was incredibly important and over half of them worried about how they looked on a daily to weekly basis. That stuff, that insecurity sticks. Because once you start thinking those thoughts of like, am I ugly? Should I lose some weight? Why don't I look like that person? How can I look like that? Why does my nose look like that? Why do my clothes look like that? There are a few days when you don't think of thought like that, even quietly, perhaps even for the rest of your life. I think something else that's interesting is that different domains or categories of insecurity are going to not only impact people differently, the way body image impacts people
对英国一群11至16岁青少年的体形进行了测量，发现79%的人认为自己的外表极其重要，超过一半的人每天到每周都会担心自己的外表。这种东西，这种不安全感会挥之不去。因为一旦你开始萌生这些想法，比如：我很丑吗？我应该减减肥吗？为什么我长得不像那个人？我怎么才能长成那样？为什么我的鼻子长这样？为什么我的衣服长这样？有几天你不会产生这样的想法，哪怕是静静地，甚至可能余生都是如此。我认为另一个有趣的事是，不同领域或类别的不安全感不仅会以不同方式影响人们，体形影响人们的方式
differently, but are going to be more prevalent in certain groups based on how we are socially conditioned. It's probably something I should have addressed actually a lot earlier on, probably very at the beginning of the episode, so apologies, but insecurity is not just this one thing. Somebody can have deep financial insecurity, but amazing image insecurity. They can be really worried about money and whether they have enough but feel great about themselves. They can have terrible professional insecurity, amazing social and relationship security. To list some of the main categories of insecurity, we have social insecurity, image insecurity, relationship insecurity, professional insecurity, financial insecurity, intellectual insecurity,
也各不相同，而且根据我们的社会规训，它们在某些群体中会更为普遍。这可能是我其实应该在更早的时候，也就是这集的开头就讨论的事情，所以在此道歉，但不安全感并非只有这么单一的东西。一个人可能会有深深的财务不安全感，但形象不安全感却很好。他们可能会非常担心钱以及自己是否有足够的钱，但对自我感觉良好。他们可能会有糟糕的职业不安全感，但社交和人际关系安全感极佳。列举一些不安全感的主要类别，我们有社交不安全感、形象不安全感、人际关系不安全感、职业不安全感、财务不安全感、智力不安全感、
health insecurity, like, it's like flavors of ice cream. Like there, it goes on and on and on. There's so many. Which type of insecurity you display most as an adult is highly revealing of what emotional battle you went through as a child or teenager. If you think about yourself, everything you know about yourself, which one is most prominent for you? And what does it trace back to? What was the origin point? What's the ancestry of your insecurity? More often than not, we can find a psychological, social or emotional origin to our primary insecurity. The death of a parent from an illness
健康不安全感，就像，就像冰淇淋的口味。就像，它没完没了。种类太多了。你在成年后表现出哪种类型的不安全感，高度揭示了你作为儿童或青少年时经历过什么情感之战。如果你回想自己，回想你对自己的了解，哪一个对你而言最为突出？它能追溯到什么？源头是什么？你内心的不安全感有什么根源？大体上，我们都能在主要的不安全感中找到心理、社交或情感上的根源。因疾病失去父母
that increases health insecurity, not feeling like you had somebody who believed in you as a child or who was a role model, increases career insecurity, being relentlessly teased about a certain physical feature, image insecurity. Honestly, with the hindsight of adulthood, you'll be surprised how many epiphanies you start having of like, wow, of course I am the way I am. How could I not be? How could I not be this person when that was my past? That was my conditioning. I was made to feel bad about this since like the day I could I could think about myself as a human. So what is the cost of insecurity? Next question. You can see we're moving through this quickly. Strangely, it's not always what you think. I think there's this typical idea that someone who is insecure will perhaps be very reclusive.
会增加健康不安全感，觉得自己小时候没有遇到相信自己或成为自己榜样的人会增加职业不安全感，因某个身体特征而遭到无休止的取笑则会导致形象不安全感。说实话，带着成年的后见之明，你会惊讶于自己开始产生多少顿悟，比如：哇，我当然是现在这个样子。我怎么可能不是呢？当那是我的过去时，我怎么可能不是这个人？那是我的规训。从我懂事、能把自己当成一个人来思考的那天起，我就因为这个而被弄得很沮丧。那么，不安全感的代价是什么？下一个问题。你可以看到我们在快速推进。奇怪的是，它并不总是你想象的那样。我认为有一种典型的观点认为，不安全感的人可能会非常隐居。
They'll shrink away, very silent, baggy clothes, very softly spoken. That's definitely one way it presents in a kind of silent self-sabotage or just a silence. But the mind and the mind of the ego find many creative ways to protect us. And one of those ways is counterintuitively through artificial overconfidence. Sometimes the loudest person in the room, the one you're like most afraid of, is deep down the one who's most afraid themselves. They are most afraid that they will be found out. They're equally convinced that one day everybody's going to realize why they hate themselves and that they should hate them for the same reasons. They mask this deep insecurity and sadness with bravado. It's what we call a compensatory defense mechanism.
他们会退缩，非常沉默，穿着宽松的衣服，说话非常轻声细语。这绝对是它的一种表现形式，表现为一种无声的自我破坏或仅仅是沉默。但心智和自我的心智找到了许多创造性的方法来保护我们。而其中一种方法，与直觉相反，是通过人为的过度自信。有时，房间里声音最大、你最害怕的那个人，内心深处往往正是最害怕自己的人。他们最害怕自己被识破。他们同样确信，总有一天每个人都会意识到他们为什么讨厌自己，并且会因为同样的原因讨厌他们。他们用虚张声势来掩盖这种深深的不安全感和悲伤。这就是我们所谓的补偿性防御机制。
And one 2013 study found that it's deeply correlated to self-doubt, not actual confidence, as we would think it was. Like, it's not arrogance, it's self-doubt. Now, as to why some people use overconfidence to mask insecurity and others don't, we actually don't really know yet, but researchers do have a theory that it has to do with social signaling. So we want to send out as many positive signals about our skills as we can, especially if we're insecure about them. And we kind of hope that if we send out heaps of signals, heaps of positive messaging, heaps of arrogant messaging, more people will believe that that's who we are and we will be able to believe it ourselves. It's almost like it is fake it to you make it on a mass scale. And the instinct to fake it
而2013年的一项研究发现，它与自我怀疑深度相关，而不是像我们想象的那样与真正的自信相关。就像，这不是傲慢，这是自我怀疑。现在，至于为什么有些人用过度自信来掩盖不安全感而其他人则不然，我们实际上还不是很清楚，但研究人员确实有一个理论，认为这与社会信号传递有关。所以我们想尽可能多地发出关于我们技能的积极信号，尤其是如果我们对它们感到不安全的话。我们有点希望，如果我们发出大量的信号、大量的积极信息、大量的傲慢信息，更多的人会相信那就是我们，我们也将能够自己相信这一点。这几乎就像是大规模的“假装直到你成功”。而假装直到你成功的
until we make it is coming from this place of deep insecurity. But because we aren't doing this from an organic natural place, we kind of don't know what the correct level that is natural confidence would look like. And we don't know when to turn it off. And then so eventually it doesn't look that great from the outside because we're not doing it in a normal way. Of course, this protection mechanism doesn't work. Bravado, arrogance, overconfidence, there will always be cracks. There's always going to be the need for further compensatory behaviors to help you keep up this facade because deep down, we don't have a well of positive regard or a well of positive thoughts or feelings about ourselves to draw from. We just don't have it. It can also
本能来自于这种深深的不安全感。但因为我们不是出于一个有机自然的地方来做这件事，我们有点不知道自然的自信应该是什么水平。而且我们不知道什么时候该收敛。所以最终它从外面看并不是很好，因为我们不是以正常的方式在做这件事。当然，这种保护机制并不管用。虚张声势、傲慢、过度自信，总会有裂痕。总会需要进一步的补偿行为来帮助你维持这种虚假的外表，因为内心深处，我们没有源源不断的积极评价，也没有源源不断的积极想法或对自己的感觉可以汲取。我们就是没有。它还
start to develop into using others to feel better in nasty ways, like putting them down, like gossiping about them, like not helping them when we know we should for fear that others shining very brightly will make us personally look worse. That's one of the worst forms that insecurity can take. It's still understandable, but it can be difficult to deal with on both sides. It's a particular form of validation seeking link to social comparison theory, but also a very specific kind of anxiety called status anxiety. There was a study from 2005 that looked at the nature of status insecurity.
可能开始演变成以令人讨厌的方式利用他人来让自己感觉更好，比如贬低他们，比如八卦他们，比如在我们明知应该帮忙时却不帮忙，生怕别人光芒万丈会让我们个人显得更糟。这是不安全感可能采取的最糟糕的形式之一。这仍然是可以理解的，但双方处理起来可能会很困难。这是一种与社会比较理论相关的特定形式的寻求认同，但也有一种非常特殊的焦虑，叫做地位焦虑。2005年有一项研究探讨了地位不安全感的本质。
They basically define it as whether somebody does or doesn't doubt their level of respect or admiration in a group. And across 17 studies, they looked at all these different ways that status anxiety shows up in society. Literally one of the ways they did this was that they randomly analyzed the final speeches from the reality showed Survivor, such a weird experimental method. They did some more serious stuff. Like they did a bunch of observational studies.
他们基本上将其定义为某人在群体中是否对自己的尊重或崇拜水平存在怀疑。在17项研究中，他们观察了地位焦虑在社会中表现出来的所有这些不同方式。他们做到这一点的方法之一，字面意思就是随机分析了真人秀节目《幸存者》中的最后发言，这真是一个奇怪的实验方法。他们做了一些更严肃的事情。比如他们做了一堆观察性研究。
They did a bunch of like experimental work as well looking into status insecurity. And what they found was that when people are status insecure, cure, they tend to believe that status is a zero-sum game or a zero-sum resource, whereby if Sally was to receive a boost, okay, Sally's a friend of mine, I'll use a different name, if Billy was to receive a boost in status, you would lose out, Gemma would lose out. And so we become protective, we become reluctant to celebrate or champion other people because we think their gain is our loss. and it makes us very not aggressive, not insecure, but just very alert. Ironically, what the study also showed was that the more people clamour for status,
他们还做了一堆实验性工作来调查地位不安全感。他们发现的是，当人们对地位感到不安全时，他们倾向于认为地位是一个零和博弈或零和资源，因此，如果萨利得到提升——好吧，萨利是我的朋友，我换个名字——如果比利在地位上得到提升，你就会吃亏，杰玛就会吃亏。因此我们变得具有防备心，我们变得不愿意去赞美或支持其他人，因为我们认为他们的收获就是我们的损失。这让我们变得很不具有攻击性、不安全，但又非常警惕。具有讽刺意味的是，研究还显示，人们越是叫嚷着要地位，
the more they want status, the more they perform behaviors that typically make people like them less, therefore making them even more insecure. There is a terrible cycle going on here that we can recognize. In contrast, people who were more secure in these studies, they gave credit to other people status. They said, Billy's doing your great job. Billy is such a great team player. They saw status as less important.
他们越是想要地位，他们就会表现出更多通常会让别人更不喜欢他们的行为，从而让他们变得更加不安全。这里正在发生一个我们能够认出的可怕循环。相比之下，这些研究中更有安全感的人，他们肯定了其他人的地位。他们说，比利做得真棒。比利是一个非常棒的团队合作者。他们认为地位没那么重要。
They believed that everybody could win. And that in turn actually made them more popular, made their status greater, and also made them more confident because of that organic social validation. It just goes to show how insecurity, like, it just twists our reality to be something that it's not, both in terms of our thoughts about ourselves and that we're these bad people, but also in terms of it convinces us to do things that actually don't help us. They don't make us more popular. They don't make us happier.
他们相信每个人都能赢。而这反过来实际上让他们更受欢迎，让他们的地位更高，也因为这种有机社会验证而让他们更加自信。这恰恰表明，不安全感如何扭曲了我们的现实，使其变成它本来的样子，不仅体现在我们对自己是这种坏人的想法上，而且还体现在它说服我们去做那些实际上对我们没有帮助的事情上。它们没有让我们更受欢迎。它们没有让我们更快乐。
They don't make us successful. They don't make us feel more secure. I think this is a deeply important takeaway from this episode, both in terms of calling out our own behavior at times, but also being aware of why others act the way they do towards you, when you're doing well, when you feel like you're achieving. Arrogance is rarely pure of origin. It's often masking something a lot harder to understand and work through,
它们没有让我们成功。它们没有让我们感觉更有安全感。我认为这是本集一个意义深远的核心收获，既体现在有时要指出我们自己的行为，也体现在意识到当你在做得很好、当你觉得自己取得成就时，为什么其他人会以那种方式对待你。傲慢很少有纯粹的根源。它往往是在掩盖一些更难以理解和克服的东西，
and that is fear, and that is disappointment in ourselves. So overconfidence, bravado, they are coping mechanisms, they are facades. They actually, they have a specific scientific name that I should use. They're called overactive or exaggerated defense mechanisms. We can also have underactive, avoidant mechanisms in response to our insecurity. The biggest one you may know of, in response to feeling insecure, we become people-pleases, whereby we further downgrade our own desires, our own needs, our own sense of self in an attempt
那就是恐惧，那就是对我们自己的失望。所以过度自信、虚张声势，它们是应对机制，它们是虚伪的外表。它们实际上，它们有一个我应该使用的具体的科学名称。它们被称为过度活跃或夸张的防御机制。为了应对不安全感，我们也可以有活跃度不足的、回避型的机制。你可能知道的最大的一个，为了应对不安全感，我们变成了讨好型人格，从而我们进一步降低了我们自己的欲望、我们自己的需求、我们自己的自我意识，企图
to gain external validation and in an attempt to plug an emotional hole that tells us we're not good enough. I think we all know what people pleasing looks like these days, but for a little bit of a revision, you know, it's overcommitting to plans with people you don't like. It's agreeing with people when you deeply know you don't agree with them and that's okay, but you just can't bring yourself to do it. Always going out of your way to do things for people, even though it's like deeply inconvenient for you, you know they're not going to do it back. Even just small, I say small, not so small things, like constantly apologizing, constantly paying for things, constantly taking the blame for others, for things that just like aren't your fault, workplace things, friendship
获得外部验证，并试图填补一个告诉我们自己不够好的情感空洞。我想现在大家都知道讨好型人格是什么样的了，但为了稍微复习一下，你知道的，就是过度承诺去参加那些你不喜欢的人的聚会。当你内心深处明明知道自己不同意、而且这其实也没关系，但你就是无法说服自己去反对时，却还是随声附和。总是竭尽全力为别人做事，尽管这对你来说极其不方便，而且你知道他们不会回报你。甚至只是微小的，我说微小，其实不太小的事情，比如不断道歉、不断为事情买单、不断为别人的事情承担责任，而这些事情根本不是你的错，比如工作上的事情、友谊
things, relationship things. Once again, people pleasing is rooted, not in manipulation. It's not even rooted in kindness. It's rooted in something. I guess it's straight down the middle. Fear. Fear that somebody won't like you. Fear that they will abandon you. Fear that all your fears about yourself will come true. All your deep insecurities will come true if you cannot get this person's positive opinion of you.
上的事情、恋爱关系中的事情。再说一次，讨好型人格的根源，不在于操纵。甚至不是根源于善良。它根源于某种东西。我想它正好介于中间。恐惧。害怕别人不喜欢你。害怕他们会抛弃你。害怕你对自己所有的恐惧都会成真。如果你无法获得这个人对你的积极看法，你所有内心深处的不安全感都会成真。
It also stems from this belief once more that love is not only conditional. Love is also an exchange. People liking you and giving you approval is an exchange. If the other person doesn't feel like they're getting something, from you or your relationship, it's not going to be worthwhile for them because your worth is only what you can provide. You do not have worth intrinsically. It is only what you can give other people. The psychoanalyst Donald Winnicott theorized that this behavior is rooted in infancy to begin with and it's rooted specifically and linked to the development of what he called the false self.
它还再次源于这样一种信念：爱不仅是有条件的。爱也是一种交换。人们喜欢你并给予你认可是一种交换。如果对方觉得他们没有从你或你们的关系中得到什么，那对他们来说就不值得，因为你的价值仅仅在于你能提供什么。你本身并不具备价值。它仅仅在于你能给予其他人什么。精神分析学家唐纳德·温尼科特（Donald Winnicott）建立了一个理论：这种行为最初根源于婴儿期，并且具体根源于并联系到他所谓的“虚假自我”的发展。
We talked about this in an episode recently, but according to this Guardian article on this, Winnicott thought that the false self emerges when a baby intuitively senses that their carer does not have the capacity to manage their true feelings, their hunger, their needs, their rage, their love, their pain. And so the false self takes over and fills up that space where the true sense of self might grow through obligation of through the need to take care of ourselves. And this child then becomes an adolescent, who then becomes an adult who realizes that nobody can fulfill my needs. I have to fulfill them myself. I have to not just fulfill my needs, but I have to prove to other people that I'm worthy of loving because I didn't get that when
我们最近在一期节目中讨论过这一点，但根据《卫报》关于这篇报道的文章，温尼科特认为，当婴儿直观地感觉照顾者没有能力应对他们的真实感受、他们的饥饿、他们的需求、他们的愤怒、他们的爱、他们的痛时，虚假自我就会出现。于是虚假自我接管并填补了那个空间，在这个空间里，真正的自我意识本可以通过责任感或照顾自己的需要而成长。这个孩子随后成为了一名青少年，然后成为了一名成年人，他意识到没有人能满足我的需求。我必须自己满足它们。我不但必须满足我的需求，还必须向其他人证明我值得被爱，因为我在
I was a kid. And therefore, it exists two versions of us if you've been through this process. The version of us that would make us happy and that would be supported by others, and a version of us that makes others happy, we choose that second version to exist because we know we can rely on ourselves, we don't know that we can rely on other people, but also because it means more external validation, which is something that we feel is more valuable than internal validation. As we continue to make that choice, we choose the false self, we choose the other self, we choose them again and again and again, the true self slowly dies and disappears. And it is one of the greatest cost of insecurity. In our efforts to become more likable, more loved, we just don't know who we are anymore.
小时候没有得到过那个。因此，如果你经历过这个过程，就会存在两个版本的我们。那个会让我们快乐并会得到其他人支持的版本的我们，和一个让其他人快乐的版本的我们，我们选择第二个版本存在，因为我们知道我们可以依靠自己，我们不知道自己是否可以依靠其他人，但也因为这意味着更多的外部验证，这是我们觉得比内部验证更有价值的东西。当我们继续做出那种选择时，我们选择了虚假自我，我们选择了另一个自我，我们一次又一次地选择它们，真实的自我慢慢消亡并消失了。这是不安全感带来的最大代价之一。为了变得更讨人喜欢、更受人喜爱，我们只是不再知道自己是谁了。
We don't know what it is that they even see in us. So how do we begin to unravel and address our insecurity? Next question for the episode. Next big question for the episode. We're going to talk about that and so much more after this short break. So stay with us. You've heard the chaos. Now you can see it. Do we want to jump around? And watch all your favorite podcasts from start to finish right inside the free IHard Radio app. Make some noise. Oohie! Catch every laugh and eye roll on shows like Bestie Listen, Hey Jonas and Las Culturistas.
我们甚至不知道他们在我们身上看到了什么。那么，我们如何开始解开并解决我们的不安全感？本集的下一个问题。本集的下一个重大问题。短暂休息后，我们将讨论这个以及更多内容。所以请继续收听。你已经听过了混乱。现在你可以看到了。我们想四处看看吗？在免费的iHeart Radio应用程序内，从头到尾观看所有你最喜欢的播客。制造点动静。哦呀！在像《Bestie Listen》、《Hey Jonas》和《Las Culturistas》这样的节目中捕捉每一个笑声和白眼。
Now with full video. I'll just leave that there. It's the same hosts and the same chemistry with all the hilarious moments you've been missing right on your screen. Open the free IHard radio app. Search video podcasts and tap watch. What's up fam? I'm sports journalist Ari Chambers. Hey, what's up y'all?
现在有了完整视频。我只想把这个留在那里。它拥有相同的主持人和相同的默契，所有你一直错过的爆笑时刻，直接呈现在你的屏幕上。打开免费的iHeart Radio应用程序。搜索视频播客并点击“观看”。家人们好吗？我是体育记者阿里·钱伯斯。嘿，你们好啊！
It's your girl, Sam J. And we're the host of everyone watches women's sports, a new podcast from Together and I Heart Women's Sports. Because let's be real. Women's sports is giving us way too much to talk about these days. So Kelsey Finler, she became the first female solo rower to go from California to Hawaii. My first thought is like, what's up with the snacks?
我是你们的女孩萨姆·J。我们是《每个人都在看女子体育》的主持人，这是一档来自Together和I Heart Women's Sports的全新播客。因为说实话。如今女子体育给我们提供了太多的话题。所以凯尔西·芬勒，她成为了第一位单人划船从加利福尼亚到夏威夷的女性。我的第一反应是，零食怎么样？
Like, what are we eating? The highlights, the rivalries, the breakout stars, the moments to take over your entire timeline. And the conversations that start during the game and somehow keep going all. week. Every week, we're breaking down the biggest stories across women's sports. Naomi Osaka showing out.
我们吃什么？亮点、竞争、崭露头角的明星、霸占你整个时间线的时刻。以及从比赛期间开始、不知为何一整周都在继续的对话。每周，我们都在剖析女子体育界的最大新闻。大阪直美大放异彩。
She beat Sabalinka. Shout out to you, Naomi. You get the palm, Naomi. You get the palm for that. Because we're not just interested in what happened. We're interested in why everyone's talking about it. Because everyone watches women's sports. Listen to everyone watches women's sports. On the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcast
她击败了萨巴伦卡。向你致敬，大阪直美。你赢得了赞誉，大阪直美。你为此赢得了赞誉。因为我们不仅对发生了什么感兴趣。我们对为什么每个人都在谈论它感兴趣。因为每个人都在看女子体育。收听《每个人都在看女子体育》。在iHeart Radio应用程序上。Apple Podcasts
or wherever you get your podcast. Hey, Portlandia fans. Carrie Brownstein and Fred Armisen here. You know us or rather you know them. Tony and Kearer. Candice, Nina and Lance, Spike, and yes, The Chicken. We've played a lot of iconic characters over the years, but today we're showing up as ourselves to tell you about Podlandia, AEO rewatch, our brand new podcast.
或任何你获取播客的地方。嘿，波特兰迷们。凯莉·布朗斯坦和弗莱德·阿米森在此。你们认识我们，或者更确切地说，你们认识他们。托尼和基勒。坎迪斯、妮娜和兰斯、斯派克，还有，没错，那只鸡。这些年来我们扮演过很多标志性的角色，但今天我们以自己的身份出现，来向你们介绍我们的全新播客《波特兰迷：爱荷华重看版》。
Each week we'll revisit an episode of Portlandia from the very beginning, breaking down the sketches, exploring the backstories of our most iconic characters, revisiting the Portland locations you know and love, and opening up about our creative process. How did any of this get made? Why do we think that was a good idea? We're ready to talk about it. about it. And we'll also be joined by the people who helped bring it all to life.
每周我们将重温《波特兰迷》从最初开始的一集，剖析小品，探索我们最具标志性角色的背景故事，重温你们熟悉和喜爱的波特兰外景地，并敞开心扉谈论我们的创作过程。这一切到底是怎么制作出来的？为什么我们当时会觉得那是个好主意？我们准备好聊聊了。聊聊这个。而且还将有帮助这一切实现的幕后功臣加入我们。
Guestrars, collaborators and friends, including director Jonathan Chrysall, the mayor himself, Kyle McLaughlin, legendary musician Amy Mann, and many more. Kyle is going for it here. You fully improvised, not just words, but a song. Well, I thought he was going to write. I thought you were all going to write a song. I remember you thinking that. Listen to Podlandia. Ayo, rewatch on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. I'm Nick Terturo.
客串明星、合作者和朋友，包括导演乔纳森·克里萨尔、市长本人凯尔·麦克拉克伦、传奇音乐家艾米·曼恩等等。凯尔在这里全力以赴。你完全即兴发挥了，不仅是台词，还有一首歌。嗯，我以为他会写。我以为你们所有人都会写首歌。我记得你是这么想的。收听《波特兰迷》。爱荷华重看版，在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。我是尼克·图图罗。
You probably know me from NYPD Blue, the longest yard, or Spike Lee's Black Klansman. But I'm also from Queens, which means I know pizza. And on my new podcast, delivering happiness with Nick Tatourl, I deliver pizza from Prince Street pizza
你可能通过《纽约重案组》、《最长的一码》或斯派克·李的《黑色党徒》认识我。但我也来自皇后区，这意味着我懂披萨。在我的新播客《尼克·图图罗的传递幸福》中，我把来自王子街披萨店的披萨
to a new guest. Are you delivering pizza now? Then we sit down for a real conversation. I've shared a slice with everyone, from Seth Rollins. What are you doing, my belt? To Alex Rodriguez. Just to let you people know,
送到一位新嘉宾手中。你现在开始送披萨了吗？然后我们坐下来进行一次真正的对话。我和每个人都分享过一块披萨，从赛斯·罗林斯。你在干什么，我的金腰带？到亚历山大·罗德里格斯。只想让你们这些人知道，
we're talking to one of the goats here. To Bill Burr. I don't think I've, ever met somebody so exactly out of their mind as I am. And now, we even have more great guests coming up, including the great John Tuturo. It's called Happiness. Delivering Happiness. Mariano Rivera.
我们这里谈论的是史上最伟大的人之一。到比尔·伯尔。我想我从来没有见过像我这样如此彻底疯狂的人。现在，我们还将迎来更多伟大的嘉宾，包括伟大的约翰·图图罗。它叫做幸福。传递幸福。马里亚诺·里维拉。
Oh, my God. And many, many more. Open your free high-heart radio app. Search Delivering Happiness with Nick Totoro. And listen now. This is Chelsea handler from Dear Chelsea. Every week, the news gets worse. The world gets crazier.
哦，天哪。还有很多很多。打开你的免费iHeart Radio应用程序。搜索《尼克·图图罗的传递幸福》。现在就收听。我是来自《亲爱的切尔西》的切尔西·汉德勒。每周，新闻都变得更糟。世界变得更疯狂。
And Yamanika is here to tell whoever's responsible, you're the problem. If you come over here to play games, I'm a check you. Okay? If you do some in the news that don't sound good, I'm going to play you. Join Yomeneka Saunders as she breaks down the week's most problematic stories on her new podcast. You're the problem with Yamanika. Do you know I just found out who Sidney Sweeney was? New episodes weekly every Wednesday is part of my new network, the Dear Chelsea Network.
亚曼妮卡在这里告诉任何负责人，你才是问题所在。如果你到这里来玩游戏，我会管教你的。好吗？如果你在新闻里做了一些听起来不太好的事，我会曝光你。加入亚曼妮卡·桑德斯，她在她的新播客中剖析本周最具问题的故事。亚曼妮卡的《你才是问题所在》。你知道我刚刚发现西德尼·西妮是谁吗？每周三更新新节目，这是我的新网络“亲爱的切尔西网络”的一部分。
If he got a bunch of women, then I should have a bunch of men. do better or do less so I don't have to do so much. So join Yamanika each episode as she answers one question. Who's the problem? I'm Yamanika and I'm out. Listen to you're the problem with Yamanika on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. So how do we address insecurity when it sits at the deepest levels of our personhood?
如果他有一群女人，那么我也应该有一群男人。做得更好或者做得更少，这样我就不必做那么多了。所以每集都加入亚曼妮卡，她回答一个问题。谁才是问题所在？我是亚曼妮卡，我先走一步。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听亚曼妮卡的《你才是问题所在》。那么，当不安全感植根于我们人格的最深处时，我们该如何解决它？
It's a pretty big question. We're basically asking, yeah, we're basically asking, yeah, we're basically. asking how do I love myself after 20 years of thinking that I shouldn't, maybe longer? How do I turn back time? How do I restructure my self-concept, my identity, the things that I never think about because they naturally came up with me? Hopefully it goes without saying podcast episode is a nice place to start. It can't take you all the way there. There's a lot of work that needs to be done individually and with a therapist. However, we can begin by questioning why everyone else can make mistakes. Everyone else can have imperfections and we can like them for their
这是一个相当大的问题。我们基本上是在问，是的，我们基本上是在问，是的，我们基本上。是在问：在认为自己不应该这样想了20年甚至更久之后，我该如何爱自己？我该如何时光倒流？我该如何重构我的自我概念、我的身份，那些我从未想过的事情，因为它们自然而然地伴随着我？不用说也知道，播客节目是一个很好的起点。它无法让你完全达到目标。有很多工作需要我们独自完成，或者与治疗师一起完成。然而，我们可以从质问为什么其他人可以犯错开始。其他人可以有缺点，我们可以因为他们的
imperfections. Everyone else can be complex, but you can't. Why do you get to be the exception to the rule? Why are you so uniquely unlikable? I think it's almost like playing uno reverse on our insecurity, as in why do you think we're so special that we can't be like everyone else? Deeply flawed, imperfect and still worthwhile. Why are we above self-acceptance? I think this creates a bit of an internal system error. How can we have these two opposing truths be correct at the same time? I'm worthless, I'm not special, I'm insecure to the point where I have nothing good about me, but I'm also worth so much that I'm the only person who could possibly be perfect. Like those two things can't exist at the same time. It's a contradiction. That is step one, slowly revealing the lies that insecurity
缺点而喜欢他们。其他人可以很复杂，但你却不行。为什么你可以成为规则的例外？为什么你如此独特地令人讨厌？我认为这就像是对我们的不安全感玩了一次“反转卡”，比如为什么你认为我们这么特殊，以至于我们不能像其他人一样？有着深深的缺陷、不完美却依然很有价值。为什么我们凌驾于自我接受之上？我认为这会产生一点内部系统错误。这两个对立的真理怎么可能同时正确呢？我很无能，我不特别，我不安全到觉得自己一无是处，但我也很有价值，以至于我是唯一一个可能完美的人。就像这两件事不能同时存在一样。这是一个矛盾。
is so great at selling you, that one included. It's so important to realize the irony and the contradictions of insecurity because once you start realizing it doesn't make a logical sense, it becomes harder to just like willingly obey. The thing that really fuels insecurity is this false belief that if you were to fix this thing about yourself, then the next thing, and then the next thing, and then the next thing, you will finally reach an end point where you don't need to change it all.
这就是第一步，慢慢揭露不安全感擅长兜售的谎言，包括那一个。认识到不安全感的讽刺之处和矛盾之处非常重要，因为一旦你开始意识到它在逻辑上讲不通，你就更难盲目地服从了。真正助长不安全感的是这样一个虚假的信念：如果你解决了关于你自己的这件事，然后是下一件事，再下一件事，接着又是一件事，你最终会达到一个终点，在那里你不需要做任何改变。
And you will finally be happy. It's what drives people to surgery addictions. It's what drives people to greed. You know, you will only be worthy when there's nothing left to criticize and you can get to that level by just consuming and claiming and just going as far as you can. This is a false destination. You're never going to get there. It is a psychological mirage that you can be 100% happy with yourself all the time. And it keeps you trapped in this mindset of self-hatred that you implicitly think is protecting you. There's another paradox at the heart of insecurity, which is that the more time we spend thinking about ourselves in our attempts to outsmart our insecurity, or in our attempts to
你终将获得幸福。这就是驱使人们对整容上瘾的原因。这就是驱使人们贪婪的原因。你知道，只有当没有什么可批评的时候，你才是有价值的，而你可以通过不断消费、索取并尽可能走得远来达到那个水平。这是一个虚假的终点。你永远到达不了那里。这是一个心理海市蜃楼，让你觉得自己可以百分之百地一直对自己感到满意。它让你陷入这种自我憎恶的心态中，而你潜意识里认为这能保护你。不安全感的核心还有另一个悖论，那就是我们花在思考自己身上的时间越多，试图智胜我们的不安全感，或者试图
find contradictory evidence, the more insecure we become. This has a name. It's called the self-absorption paradox. The more time you spend thinking about yourself, the more critical you become of yourself is what the theory says. And what research is investigating this phenomena often talk about is that Sometimes the only way to tackle insecurity is just to think about yourself less and to just focus more on the outside world. It's to just be like, I'm really not that important, which is ironic because insecurity would already have us feel that way. Think it a little bit more. This isn't to belittle our experiences of insecurity. Being insecure is crippling.
寻找反面证据，我们就会变得越不安全。这有一个名字。它被称为自我专注悖论。理论说，你花在思考自己身上的时间越多，你对自己的批判性就越强。而研究这一现象的研究人员经常谈到的是，有时解决不安全感的唯一方法就是少想一点自己，多关注外部世界。就是表现得像，我真的没那么重要，这很具有讽刺意味，因为不安全感已经让我们有这种感觉了。再多想一点。这并不是要贬低我们经历的不安全感。感到不安全是令人瘫痪的。
It's terrible. Thinking about it less doesn't always work. It's tough. But sometimes the best way to chat. our insecurities is to demote their mental relevance and importance by giving our mind all this other stuff to just think about and consider and to be occupied by. If you're feeling insecure about your body, it's a lot harder to feel insecure about your body. I think if you are outside, spending time in nature, with your friends, doing things, moving, using your body in a way that is
这太糟糕了。少想一点并不总是管用。这很难。但有时解决我们不安全感的最有效方法是通过给大脑所有其他需要思考、考虑和占据的事情，来降低它们在精神上的关联度和重要性。如果你对自己的身材感到不安全，想要对自己的身材感到不安全就会困难得多。我认为如果你在户外，花时间在大自然中，和朋友们在一起，做事情，运动，以一种超出
beyond just its appearance-based value. If you're feeling bummed out by social media, it's a lot harder to feel insecure about your online presence or feel insecure about whether or not you're left out if you are active in your community, if you're volunteering, if you're picking up rubbish at your local beach, if you're finding new ways to connect to your need to belong that is beyond a screen. I hope you kind of see my point. Getting outside of your own small, tiny world and your own small, tiny mental ecosystem and emotional ecosystem allows you to see your problems in the grand scheme of things and your insecurities in the grand schemes of things. I think instead of constantly searching for evidence that your insecurities are
其外表价值的方式使用你的身体。如果你对社交媒体感到沮丧，如果你积极参与社区活动、如果你在做志愿者、如果你在当地海滩捡垃圾、如果你在寻找超越屏幕的归属感的新途径，那么要对自己的网络存在感到不安全，或者对是否被冷落感到不安全，就会困难得多。我希望你大概明白我的意思。跳出你自己的微小世界、跳出你自己的微小精神生态系统和情感生态系统，能让你在大局中看待你的问题，并在大局中看待你的不安全感。我认为与其不断寻找证据证明你的不安全感是
incorrect, just stop thinking about them as making a valid enough point to begin with that you'd have to go searching for evidence against it for. Do you know what I mean? Like, demote it. It's not even important enough to try and gather arguments for or against. Your insecurities, you do not even need to consider them as facts in the way that, like, evidence needs to be gathered. I feel like I've said the same sentence, like seven times, but I just think that that's something that you need to honor in yourself. Thinking about your insecurities also involves thinking about how you're going to disprove them. And by doing that, they just get further entrenched. Thinking about anything else, anything besides that preoccupying and filling your mind with other things is one of many antidotes.
错误的，不如就别把它当成一个从一开始就有足够说服力、以至于你必须去寻找反面证据的观点。你知道我的意思吗？把它降级。它甚至不重要到需要试图为之收集支持或反对的论据。你的不安全感，你甚至不需要把它们视为事实，不需要像收集证据那样去对待它们。我觉得我好像把同一句话说了七遍左右，但我只是觉得这是你需要对自己负责的事情。思考你的不安全感也包括思考你将如何反驳它们。通过这样做，它们只会根深蒂固。去想别的任何事情，任何能够占据和充实你心智的事情，就是众多解毒剂之一。
I believe you also deserve to interrogate, yes, where your insecurities came from like we were speaking about before and their autobiographical digging, but you need to interrogate who benefits from you being insecure. This is what I always ask myself. Me feeling bad about myself, who does this serve? Who wins from my sense? of loss or my sense of deficiency. Because it isn't me. I'm not winning from feeling insecure. Somebody is gaining from me not feeling good, whether it is economically by the fact I go out and try and buy things to make myself feel better, whether it's through opportunities that I turn down that somebody else gets to get, whether it's through love and romance where somebody benefits
我相信你也应该质疑，是的，就像我们之前谈到的那样，你的不安全感来自何处以及它们的自传式挖掘，但你需要质疑谁从你的不安全感中获利。这就是我经常问自己的问题。我对自己感觉不好，这对谁有益？谁从我的失落感或不足感中获胜？因为不是我。我没有从感到不安全中获胜。有人从我感觉不好中获益，无论是经济上通过我出去买东西来让自己感觉更好，还是通过我拒绝而别人却能得到的机遇，亦或是通过爱情和浪漫，其中有人受益于
from me not feeling good enough so that they can treat me worse. Like, somebody is always benefiting from your lack of self-worth and the fact that you don't feel like you're enough. This isn't to say that every insecurity has been deliberately imposed on you. Every insecurity, you know, somebody is puppeteering it. It's just that many have originated in a way that, you know, by people trying to correct your behavior early on through rejection, criticism, comparison, they've been trying to get you to behave in a certain way that makes their life more complex. comfortable. And once those insecurities exist, even when they're no longer useful for the person
我感觉自己不够好，这样他们就可以对我更差。就像，总有人从你缺乏自我价值感以及你觉得自己不够好这件事中获益。这并不是说每一种不安全感都是故意强加给你的。每一种不安全感，你知道的，都有人在背后操纵。只是许多不安全感的起源在于，你知道的，人们试图通过拒绝、批评、比较在早期纠正你的行为，他们一直试图让你以某种让他们的生活更舒适的方式行事。而一旦这些不安全感存在了，即使它们对那个最初在你体内植入它的人来说不再有用，它们对其他机构也变得有用了。它们在工作中对你的老板变得有用，因为你不需要向你提供更多，因为你不会索取。它们在浪漫中再次变得有用，人们不需要对你很好。它们对大公司和友谊变得有用，他们从你觉得（你知道的）他们陪你是在为你效劳、你需要买他们的产品中获益。
who originally implanted it in you, they become useful for other institutions. They become useful at work for your boss, you know, not needing to give you anything more because you don't ask for it. They become useful, again, in romance, people not having to treat you well. They become useful to big companies and to friendships who benefit from you feeling like, you know, they're doing you a service by hanging out with you, that you need to buy their product. If my insecurity is costing me, it must be paying somebody else. Therefore, there is something to be gained from my own unconditional self-love. There is something that they are gaining that I get to take back. More freedom, more time, more money, more openness to experiences, more opportunities, more
如果我的不安全感让我付出了代价，它一定是在回报别人。因此，我自己的无条件自爱是有利可图的。他们正在获得某种我能够夺回的东西。更多的自由、更多的时间、更多的金钱、更多对经历的开放态度、更多的机会、更多的
risks. I want those things for myself, but that means I have to be okay and I have to be fully ready to accept parts of myself that I don't think you're ready to love yet. Like that is the exchange. That is the price that I will probably have to pay. I have to be ready to part with the idea that my insecurities are in any way helpful or in any way protecting me. Once again, it's another irrational lie that your insecurities are helping you. How can something that limits me, be helpful in a world that rewards people who feel limitless, who take risks, who just like say fuck it and try. The degree to which I limit myself is the degree to which somebody else gains from my sense of limitation. That is a quote that I think of all the time, all the time.
风险。我为自己想要这些东西，但这意味着我必须安于现状，我必须完全准备好接受我那些你认为还准备好去爱的自己的部分。这就是交换。这就是我可能必须支付的代价。我必须准备好抛弃这种想法：我的不安全感在任何方面对我有帮助，或者在任何方面在保护我。再说一次，这又是一个荒谬的谎言，谎称你的不安全感在帮助你。在一个奖励那些感觉自己没有极限、敢于冒风险、只管说“去他的”并去尝试的人的世界里，怎么会有局限我的东西能提供帮助呢？我限制自己的程度，就是别人从我的局限感中获利的程度。这是一句我一直、一直都在想的名言。
Finally, finally, I know it's been a long episode, you guys have made it. Congratulations. The ultimate off switch for any momentary, pesky feeling of insecurity is just just realizing how little it's going to matter in the long run. One of the only benefits I've been able to identify to my own existential fears or my own fears around mortality and death. And genuinely, it's one of the only ones is that it's an incredible antidote to feeling bad about myself. If I think I look ugly in that dress and my stomach is poking out, who cares? I'm going to be dead one day. Immediately I feel better. If I feel cringe for posting my work online, or being seen to try too hard for an outlandish dream,
最后，终于，我知道这一集很长，你们坚持到了最后。恭喜。消除任何转瞬即逝、烦人的不安全感的终极开关，就是意识到从长远来看，这件事其实微不足道。我所能找到的关于我自己的存在主义恐惧或对死亡的恐惧的唯一好处之一。坦白说，这是唯一的解药之一，能让我不再对自己感到糟糕。如果我觉得自己穿那条裙子很难看，肚子凸出来了，那又怎样？我总有一天会死。我立刻感觉好多了。如果我觉得把作品发到网上很尴尬，或者表现得为了一个离奇的梦想而付出太多努力，
literally nobody is going to remember me or you or anybody. If I'm feeling silly or embarrassed over literally anything, I just have to remind myself my time on earth is short. Why am I wasting it on this? Genuinely, the existential approach to insecurity, like it's not one you can have all the time because we still want to connect with the fact that life has meaning, but if your insecurity is blocking you in the moment from enjoying the time that you are in,
真的没有人会记住我、你或任何人。如果我对任何事情感到愚蠢或尴尬，我只需提醒自己，我在地球上的时间是短暂的。我为什么要在这上面浪费时间？真的，用存在主义的方法来对待不安全感，你不能一直这样，因为我们仍然希望与生活是有意义的这一事实保持联系，但如果你的不安全感此刻阻碍了你享受你所处的时间，
if it's blocking you from taking a risk or a choice that you know is needed to get to the next phase or stage of life, if it's stopping you from pursuing love or pursuing something that is truly worthwhile, having that little existential moment of like, nobody's going to remember me is an amazing fix. With that in mind, Let's wrap up this episode for good. Let's finish our conversations around insecurity for the day. I really hope that you enjoyed it. I really hope that it's been a kind of a doorway into analyzing, like, where did your own insecurities come from? I feel like once I started doing this, it's a road you can't come back from. But it's so useful because when I hear these negative thoughts
如果它阻碍你做出你知道为了进入下一个阶段或时期所必需的风险或选择，如果它阻碍你追求爱情或追求真正有价值的事情，那么拥有那种“没有人会记住我”的存在主义时刻，是一个了不起的解决方法。带着这个想法，让我们好好结束这一集。今天关于不安全感的讨论就到这里。我真的希望你们喜欢这一集。我真的希望这能成为一扇门，帮助大家分析：你自己的不安全感究竟从何而来？我觉得一旦我开始这样做，这是一条无法回头的路。但它太有用了，因为当我听到这些消极想法时
about myself and my own mind, I know where they came from and I can assign them a voice that is not my own. and that has been so useful. It's also just given me so much more audacity and courage to realize that once again, I benefit in no way from being small. Only other people do. And it's, yeah, giving me a lot more bravado, but not in the, not in the toxic way as we spoke about. I want to thank our researcher Lucy Davidson for her help with this episode. If you did enjoy this episode, leave a five-star review wherever you are listening. Leave a little comment down below as well. What was your favorite takeaway from this episode? Have you made it this far?
关于我自己和我的内心，我知道它们来自哪里，我可以给它们一个不属于我自己的声音。这真的太有用了。它也给了我更多的勇气和胆量，让我意识到，我再次认识到，保持渺小对我有百害而无一利。只有对别人才有益。而且，这确实给了我更多的傲气，但不是我们谈论的那种有毒的傲气。我要感谢我们的研究员露西·戴维森（Lucy Davidson）对本集的大力协助。如果你确实喜欢这一集，请在你收听的任何地方留下五星好评。也在下方留下一点评论吧。你从这一集中最喜欢的是什么？你坚持听到这里了吗？
Show me that you're a loyal listener. Show me that you're somebody who has a great attention span and makes it to the end of podcast episodes because that's a rare thing these days. You can also follow us on Substack if you want to read this episode. I don't read this episode in written form rather than just listen to it if you want to go back to it. Take away some notes.
向我展示你是一个忠实的听众。向我展示你是一个注意力集中、能听到播客节目最后的人，因为这在当今时代很少见。如果你想阅读这一集的文字版，而不是只听音频，你也可以在 Substack 上关注我们。如果你想回顾一下，可以做一些笔记。
You can watch the podcast on Netflix. If you are not already doing so, please give it a go. Instagram, further resources. there is so much in the episode description. So go there for all your inquisitive needs, your curious click needs. Everything's downstairs. I was going to say, everything's in the description. And again, I hope you enjoyed the episode.
你可以在 Netflix 上观看这个播客。如果你还没这么做，请尝试一下。Instagram 上有更多资源。节目简介里有太多内容了。所以快去那里满足你所有的好奇心和点击欲吧。所有东西都在下方。我本想说，所有东西都在简介里。再次希望你喜欢这一集。
I really enjoyed making it. So until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. Hey, Portlandia fans. Carrie Brownstein and Fred Armisen here. The Dream of the 90s is alive in podcast form. We're launching Podlandia, A-O-Rae. rewatch, our brand new podcast where we revisit every episode of Portlandia together,
我真的很享受制作它的过程。所以直到下次，保重，保持善良，对你自己温柔一点。我们很快就会再聊。嗨，波特兰迷们。我是凯莉·布朗斯坦（Carrie Brownstein）和弗莱德·阿米森（Fred Armisen）。90 年代的梦想在播客中依然活着。我们正在推出 Podlandia, A-O-Rae. rewatch，这是一个全新的播客，我们将一起重温《波特兰迪亚》的每一集，
breaking down sketches, going deep on our iconic characters, and pulling back the curtain on how it all got made. And we'll also be joined by the people who helped bring it all to life. Guest stars, collaborators and friends, including director Jonathan Chrysall, the mayor himself, Kyle McLaughlin, legendary musician Amy Mann, and many more. Kyle is going for it here. You fully improvised, not just words, but a song. Well, I thought you were all going to write a song.
剖析小品，深入探讨我们的标志性角色，并揭开这一切是如何制作的幕后花絮。我们还将邀请那些帮助将这一切变为现实的人。特邀嘉宾、合作者和朋友，包括导演乔纳森·克里萨尔（Jonathan Chrysall）、市长本人凯尔·麦克拉克伦（Kyle McLaughlin）、传奇音乐家艾米·曼（Amy Mann）等等。凯尔在这里全力以赴。你不仅即兴发挥了歌词，还即兴发挥了一首歌。嗯，我以为你们都要写一首歌。
I remember you. Thinking that. Listen to Podlandia, AEO rewatch on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. What's up, fam? I'm sports journalist Ari Chambers. Hey, what's up, y'all? It's your girl, Sam J. And we're the host of everyone watches women's sports, a new podcast from Together and IHart Women's Sports.
我记得你。当时是这么想的。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Podlandia, AEO rewatch。怎么了，家人们？我是体育记者阿里·钱伯斯（Ari Chambers）。嘿，最近怎么样，大家？我是你们的女孩萨姆·J（Sam J）。我们是《每个人都在看女子体育》的主持人，这是一档来自 Together 和 IHart Women's Sports 的全新播客。
We're breaking down the biggest headlines. Naomi Osaka, showing out. Shout out to you, Naomi. The viral moments. I've been obsessed with Kashan Rock's boxing journey. She looks good. Her combos are swift. and the stories everyone's talking about across women's sports.
我们正在剖析最大的头条新闻。大坂直美（Naomi Osaka），表现出色。向你致敬，直美。病毒式传播的时刻。我一直对卡尚·洛克（Kashan Rock）的拳击之旅着迷。她看起来状态很好。她的组合拳很敏捷。以及每个人在整个女子体育界都在谈论的故事。
Because everyone watches women's sports. Listen to everyone watches women's sports on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcast. I'm Nick Tuturo. You probably know me from NYPD Blue, the longest yard, or Spike Lee's Black Klansman. And on my new podcast delivering happiness with Nick Tatourl, I deliver pizza to a new guest. I've shared a slice with everyone from Seth Rollins. What are you doing my belt?
因为每个人都在看女子体育。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序上收听《每个人都在看女子体育》。Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方。我是尼克·图图罗（Nick Tuturo）。你可能从《纽约重案组》、《最长的一码》或斯派克·李的《黑色党徒》中认识我。在我的新播客《与尼克·塔图尔一起传递幸福》中，我给一位新嘉宾送比萨。我与每个人分享过一块披萨，从赛斯·罗林斯（Seth Rollins）。你在对我的腰带做什么？
To Bill Burr. I don't think I've ever met somebody so exactly out of their mind. Yes, I am. And now we even have more great guests coming up, including the great John Tuturo. It's called Happiness, delivering happiness. And many, many more. Open your free High Heart Radio app.
到比尔·伯尔（Bill Burr）。我想我从来没见过谁这么精神失常。是的，我是。现在我们还将迎来更多伟大的嘉宾，包括伟大的约翰·图图罗（John Tuturo）。它叫幸福，传递幸福。还有很多很多。打开你免费的 High Heart Radio 应用程序。
Search Delivering Happiness with Nick Taturo. And listen now. This is Chelsea Handler from Dear Chelsea. Every week, the news gets worse. The world gets crazier. And Yamanika is here to tell whoever's responsible, you're the problem. Do you know I just found out who Sidney Sweeney was?
搜索《与尼克·塔图尔一起传递幸福》。立即收听。我是来自《亲爱的切尔西》的切尔西·汉德勒（Chelsea Handler）。每周，新闻都在变糟。世界变得更加疯狂。而亚玛尼卡（Yamanika）在这里告诉任何应该负责的人，你才是问题所在。你知道我刚刚发现西德尼·斯威尼（Sydney Sweeney）是谁吗？
If he got a bunch of women, then I should have a bunch of women. your men. Do better or do less so I don't have to do so much. I'm Yamanika and I'm out. Listen to you're the problem with Yamanika on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. I'm Nancy Glass, host of the Burden of Guilt Season 3 podcast. This is a story about a horrendous situation that destroyed two families. It's a scorched earth war that shows just how far someone will go to get what they want. Cindy said, I had to choose between the truth and my family, and I had to choose the truth.
如果他有一群女人，那么我也应该有一群女人。你们这些男人。要么表现得更好，要么少做一点，这样我就不用做那么多了。我是亚玛尼卡，我下班了。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方，收听 Yamanika 的《你才是问题所在》。我是南希·格拉斯（Nancy Glass），《罪恶的负担》第三季播客的主持人。这是一个关于摧毁两个家庭的可怕情况的故事。这是一场焦土战争，展示了某人为得到他们想要的东西会走多远。辛迪说，我必须在真相和我的家庭之间做出选择，我必须选择真相。
Listen to season three of Burden of Guilt on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast, guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《罪恶的负担》第三季。这是一个 IHeart 播客，保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。